those are near
this was never a trap it is a test of
metal
our battle ends here get him out of
there
bear witness
our story will become
legend
told by those
that
you
call the humans
any damage you inflict on escherim is
transferred to echo 216. the power is
transmitted via a series of relays
around the room let's see if i can
got it relays exposed destroy it
relay's down and so is his
shield my challenge
ashram shield reactivated
expose the relay
got it go
[Applause]
the shield's down now's your chance
the future of the valley
is secured
no
what
i'll have your hands
uh
the machine is connected to escherim
shield any damage you inflict on escher
is transferred to echo 216. the power is
transmitted via a series of relays
around the room let's see if i can
got it relay's exposed destroy it
relays down and so is his shield
are you free
in the name
please
shield reactivated
expose the relay
got it go
the shield's down now's your chance
you refuse to face my challenge
[Applause]
oh
next relay's exposed take it out
and it's down you know what to do
final relay is exposed destroy it
that's it last relay destroyed echo 216
is safe chief
escherim wants you to prove your legend
time to prove it
this will hurt
[Music]
no
it will be quick i can promise you that
this battle will be remembered
you
will not stop us
[Music]
[Applause]
if i'm to die today so be it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
i can't believe you came for me
so we're done now right
thousand others
[Music]
tell them
i
died
well
i don't understand
you showed him respect
he was a monster yes
but at the end he was just a soldier
hoping he'd done the right thing
questioning his choices
i
so is it over
they're leaders dead right
the intricacies of any action are
complex
what
what are you talking about there will be
consequences
there always are
what could be worse
we need to move
the harbingers at the auditorium
whatever she's planning it's worse
i get it
okay then i have one question before we
leave
what is
it
has anyone seen a pelican oh
what
what
i'm just
i had a lot going on i was busy
are you ready it's about to get rough
they're waiting for us i think they're
all waiting for us
did you feel that
it's not too late to turn around chief
something feels
the silent auditorium
oh no what is it what's wrong
i should have realized that's not what
it was called
i've been here before
this is where i locked her down
this is where cortana died
did you hear me we're here you need to
go now
[Music]